Hello my name is Adam. In this video I ‘ll
show you how to get your app uploaded in the
web store.
Until the store launches, developers will
need to use the Chrome Extension gallery’s
upload flow and developer dashboard to upload
and manage their apps. So, to get your app
in the store, go to the Chrome extensions
gallery at chrome.google.com/extensions and
click on the “Publish your extensions”
link on the left.
This will take you to our developer dashboard.
Click “Add new item” to upload a new app.
You’ll then be asked to select the zip file
that contains your app manifest. Select the
file you have created, click "Upload" and
you’ll be taken to a page where you will
need to provide some additional information
about your app.
For those of you who have developed extensions,
you will recognize a lot of the fields you
need to complete, such as uploading screenshots,
selecting the primary language for your app,
providing a detailed descriptions well as
including links to your website and support
materials. However, we have added a few more
items on this page.
First of all you can select the price of your
app - by default this is set as free but you
can change it if you want to. To do so, click
on the “Change pricing” button. This will
bring up a panel that lets you select between
3 pricing options: an option to keep your
app free, an option to use the Chrome Web
Store’s built in payment mechanism and finally
the option to use a different payment system
within your app.
The first option is intended for applications
that never charge any money, apps that are
free from end-to-end.
The second option, using the Chrome Web Store’s
payment mechanism, allows users to pay for
your app directly within the Web Store. Using
our licensing API you’ll then be able to
determine whether a given Chrome user who’s
entering your app has paid or not. If you
select this option, you will be asked to define
the price for your app from a set number of
price points. If you’re setting up a subscription-based
service, you can select whether to charge
users per month or per year.
In addition, you can specify whether users
can try a free version of the app - we call
this option “free trial”. With this option,
users can instantly start using the free version
of your app. We encourage you to integrate
free trials because users are often more willing
to spend money for an app after trying it
out.
The third option is intended for apps that
use a custom payment solution. If you’ve
integrated another payment provider, select
this option. Also select this option if the
basic version of your app is free but users
can pay for upgrades, virtual goods or other
services later.
In addition to the pricing options, you’ll
also be asked to select up to 3 app categories
under which your app should be listed in the
store. To ensure good user ratings for your
apps make sure to include your app only in
relevant categories. This list will likely
be updated before our launch, so feel free
to suggest additional categories for your
app in the free form text box.
Further down, is one more important section
for apps: We require that you verify the ownership
of the website that your app is hosted on
using Google’s Webmaster Tools. You will
see the list of verified websites that are
associated with your account in the dropdown.
To verify additional websites, click the link
and follow the instructions for Google Webmaster
Tools.
We have a lot more material on different elements
on the upload flow in our documentation located
at code.google.com/chrome/webstore. We are
looking forward to seeing your apps in the
store!